all right so you've given me a perfect
lane through gamergate to talk about
probably your other favorite thing to
talk about or at least maybe your most
controversial thing to talk about which
is feminism so let's let's go there
let's talk a little feminism I'm gonna
give you this in the most broad sense
basically you don't like what the
feminist movement has become is that
fair to say yes and the one one of the
dangers of talking about feminism is
that it's very often conflated with
women and this is done so when I do that
exactly you're a misogynist yeah last
thing you'll hear if ever you have any
complaint about feminism um however I
mean this is just obviously logically
it's not it's not it's nonsense
feminism itself as an ideology and you
get male and female feminists and you
get people who are male and female
opposed to modern feminism so the idea
that feminism is inherently the same as
women is ridiculous and the thing is
even the fewer and fewer women every
year are identifying as feminists at the
moment in it in America only about 18%
of women identify as feminists and only
some about 9% of men whereas in inside
the 70s somewhere as high as 40% so the
feminist movement is honestly I think I
don't think it's doing yourself any
favors I think it's it's gone full
regressive that's the problem you know I
I would have no problem calling myself a
feminist if we were in the era of say
second wave feminism we had you know
it's some equity feminism christina hoff
sommers or Camille Paley would be
espousing you know this the sort of
equal rights equal pay or the sort of
all sort of things that you as any
egalitarian would be completely on board
with and would find absolutely no
objection to I find an objection to but
my problem is when we start getting into
the realms of well I mean shaming
language for a start you're a misogynist
you're this about you the other when you
have any objection and quotas or any
anything like this you know and then you
then get into some conspiracy theories
patriarchy theory you know and then it
becomes intersectional so now involves
race and transsexuals and homosexuals
and and now it's a kyriaki this is an
inter linking
a series of oppressions and privileges
and really you realize that what you
what you're regurgitating is Marxist
rhetoric it's all I mean if you read the
communist manifesto you understand
modern feminism you are talking about
the male bourgeoisie and the female
proletariat and it's the same with black
and white straight and gay and all these
sort of things and I just don't describe
to that because it implies a shared
experience that we know men and women
don't have you know I mean and and not
just men and women like black people
near Trayvon Martin did not have the
same life experiences about Barack Obama
you know and so to say that being black
is some sort of inherent shared
oppression that they have is ridiculous
you know it just it doesn't work and my
main problem really is but is that it's
become anti individualistic the I mean
you get famous famous like any
sarkeesian who will literally say things
like individuals women individual
women's choices don't count
what matters is what it what matters is
feminism or the great unit something for
the greater good of feminism some of
that I can't over exactly how the the
quote goes but it was just one of those
things where it's just like okay I am so
totally against this that I think I'd be
prepared to fight a civil war against
you you know I think these are so anti
anti liberal principles I can't stand
them right so so in a way it's evolved
to where it's no longer first off women
are in a minority I think there's
something like 50 51 or 52 percent of
the population but where where you
should be for the minority in a minority
what you're saying is that their fight
it they're eliminating the minority in
the minority I think an example of that
we could use from the American political
space would be someone like Sarah Palin
now I don't like the views that Sarah
Palin espouses at all really but can you
believe that yeah I'm not a big fan of
Sarah Palin that being said she's
obviously a very influential and
powerful and self-motivated woman so in
a certain sense she's the ultimate goal
of what a feminist should be but
feminists hate her right absolutely cuz
she thinks wrong that's the problem
she she doesn't the spinals she doesn't
spell regressive ideology she doesn't I
mean if she called herself a feminist
fundamentally she wouldn't be invoking
Marxist ideas she would be invoking sort
of libertarian ideas the song strength
of the individual hard work you know the
all these honestly I think that you know
they're not they're not bad ideas at all
but she wouldn't be in the same camp as
say Gloria Steinem Steinem or bell hooks
or someone like that yeah and I I don't
it's weird talking about Marxism you
know it's really weird because I mean
almost nobody really understands it
these days but many people understand it
other academics and universities who
teach it and it is the Communist
Manifesto is the third most prescribed
book in universities in America just you
know the Communist Manifesto communism
died everywhere but in the West it's so
bizarre
well we fetishize these things right
absolutely people people who live under
communism hate communism they think it's
a terrible idea they know that you mean
they they had secured at 3:00 in the
morning for milk and eggs you know they
think is a terrible idea but the people
in the West have never lived through
being put into practice and so they
don't understand it's you know they
don't really you know this really
understand the the real true nature of
it I guess and so you know when you're
sat in a comfortable house that's been
built under a capitalistic system and
you've got lots of money you've you're
doing very well for yourself you're
thinking well maybe we should you know
maybe maybe it's not such a bad idea and
right it is it you know and but it's
these principles that inform almost
everything about third wave feminism
it's all about it's all about power
dynamics privileged and oppressed
privilege and oppress which is why I was
watching The Young Turks the other day
in fact and the Jimmy Dore I think it
was he he actually had his tongue in his
mouth and he was saying that some he was
for the oppressed in every situation so
he each of the example of Israel so in
Israel oppressed as a Palestinian man
he's in favor of the Palestinian man and
then if the Palestinian man oppresses
his wife he's in favor of the wife and
it's just like you but that you've
you've just said you are and are not in
favor of the Palestinian man there Jimmy
you know that is inherited country you
can't you can't be in favor of the man
and the wife you know at the same time
which one of you in favor of you know
it's it's that kind of it's got this
inherent contradiction to it and they
don't seem to want to acknowledge that
yeah and that's why as
you've said for a while now this this
regressive ideology it's always putting
narrative over fact that's really the
most when you Whittle it down to what it
really is it has to be narrative over
fact so you just pick the most depressed
and then you get everybody on the ladder
and then that's how you judge everybody
which is the reverse of judging a
minority within a minority and those are
the people that we should be for yeah
absolutely in the the crazy thing about
it as well is that these things are
inherently racist and sexist and you
know any other issue you want to but the
the problem is that normally when people
think are you being a racist you think
you're being a racist to the I guess the
the oppressed if that's what you want to
come you know the the minority who have
suffered from racial discrimination past
you know black people or you know you
pressing women or something on that but
racism and sexism despite what the
regressors will tell you are not
structures or systems of power their
principles their ideas they are there
they are ways of viewing the world and
so you can be racist to white people you
can be sexist to men and vice versa and
so it's this kind of like say is the
narrative they've gone out of the way to
redefine a bunch of words and then they
have cherry-picked data points to arrive
a nice location where they can say you
as a white man and not now allowed to
speak why because you're a white man and
they will literally turn around and tell
you that that is not racist and sexist I
think it's amazing you give them enough
credit to say they've picked these data
points because that I think in most
cases they haven't even gone that far
you're you're giving them the benefit of
the doubt that I can no longer give them
but we started here on feminism so let's
not go too far but but that's the
interesting thing that every time I'm
talking about all this stuff we realize
how the inter there's this interleague
theme between gamergate between feminism
all of this stuff so as far as feminism
I saw an interesting video that you did
where you took the the three types of
what you said were the three types of
male feminists um and I thought it was
really interesting because I was because
I defend women women should be equal and
that's pretty much it so you anyone can
define me however they want but I
thought the way you broke these three
type of men
down was pretty interesting can you do
that for us um god it was while ago did
that video I can't remember it um okay
so yeah it's basically about
self-interest I think I mean you get
some you get men who are they they want
to be rewarded for doing something
heroic and protective you know it's and
I think that shank might fall into this
category where he's a big guy he's not
he himself that you know that this chap
doesn't have any particular um fears in
for his own physical security and so he
thinks so I'm going to use my physical
presence to protect women because that
would be a you know laudable thing to do
and it would be except that they're
doing it for their own self-interest
they're doing it their own three their
own personal feelings um these are at
the end of the day this is a guy who
basically wants to get laid
I mean in a lot of respects I don't have
put it that way but yeah I think kind of
is it's it's and the things it's not
necessarily getting laid either I love a
lot of it is just for um just for the
sort of the emotional reward you know
because like a social cred yeah yeah and
just and just um just to get the pat on
the head you know it's it's not kind of
to feel good about themselves but
requires permission from someone else
this case being one and the thing is you
end up you end up getting release or
them really unhealthy dynamics because
you'll find women who are looking for
men to do things for and you will find
men who are looking to do things for
women and you will get this kind of
feedback loop where they'll reinforce
each other you know you this this this
guy stands up for this woman who is
using him to fight her battles and so
this guy ends up fighting battles on his
battles but are being reinforced
constantly by and again this is not like
all women in fact most women are not
like this but you will you know women
are humans too and you get bad women as
well as good women and you find that
this this is basically one of the
problems with them the progressives cuz
like we were saying earlier and I hate
to come back to like progresses but
feminism is just one like branch under
the umbrella of the progressive sort of
tree I guess you know it's it all ties
together
um but you like said you get most people
they think they're doing it for the
right reasons you know they think
while I'm a good person I need to be
helping women and minorities and gays
and trans Maya but the the problem is
that they have this kind of toolbox of
rhetoric that virtue signals to other
regressives it shows them say hey look
I'm using this kind of language
therefore I'm on your team you can come
and support me on Twitter aware arena
and and so you get people who think ok
great I'm going to do that because I
want to be an activist I'll do something
good and then you'll get the other kind
of person who is the more malicious
person who will think great I can use
this to my own advantage and they are
the people you've got to be really
worried about I mean that there's in
gamergate there was a woman called randy
harper she was actually parked game day
she should part the problem but some the
I've never seen it more starkly
represented than in her example I think
the thing was 2011-2012 she she was on a
BSD which is a programming language of
podcast and she was literally saying
well I'm a woman in tech and I don't
have a problem with this you know I
think I think the feminists are way over
blowing this problem with misogyny in
the tech industry and also stuff I'm a
woman attack I have no problem
everything's great
and lo and behold two years later when
it's shown to be a profitable business
model she is literally on Twitter saying
I'm an oppressed woman in tech I need
your money you know give me money every
month through patreon and also and it it
just the complete polar opposite of what
you're saying before and it's like
really so either the industry has become
massively sexist overnight right you
found a way to profit you know and so so
this is sort of something we could find
with any movement so I don't think I
don't think you're saying this but that
this isn't specific to feminism any
movements going to have its people who
are doing it with the right intentions
it's going to have the people that are
being guilted into it it's going to have
the people that are being tricked into
it it's gonna have the people that can
profit from it or every single movement
and you're just using feminism as one
example I don't want people to say well
you see he's trying to muck up what
feminism is or something to that effect
ya know it's you write this this is and
again it's not necessarily feminism
because feminism is just a subsection of
the social justice movement you know
you've got some they call it into
sectionalism
now which is um like there's a reason
bell hooks describes it as the white
supremacist capitalist patriarchy
and that's surprising you you are you
are a supporter of the white supremacist
capitalist patriarchy day yeah and if I
actively propagate I'm a terrible person
but basically what this encompasses is
the dynamics between black people and
white people the white supremacy the
capitalism is the poor enriched and the
patriarchy being men and women and I
think they probably have terms for gay
and straight and trans and says but I'm
not familiar with them off my head but
this is this is the point it's um they
have this toolbox of terms and they have
a big academic backing all of this comes
from academia all of it you know this is
all been and people think oh this is
coming from tumblr so no tumblr is the
outgrowth it's cancer you know the this
is it coming to the surface in popular
culture this all comes from sort of you
know the brightly lit halls of academia
where they they start with a premise
they confirm their biases they
peer-review their own papers between
feminists and then they carry on
building from that until they've got to
the point where they will and it like I
said the redefinition of things the
reason the reason regressives are so
dangerous is of course as you said with
every movement you're going to get
people who are profiteering you need
people doing it for selfish reasons but
I can't think of any movement that
legitimately has an excuse to be
malevolent to people for any good reason
you know almost every single only like
the christy is will love you love your
neighbor as yourself you know and look
further individualist to see in an
individual rights and represented
democracy everyone gets to be treated in
a universal manner you know the
brotherhood of man all that sort of
thing whereas these people have
something different they actually have
and I come up which feminists it is and
I'm quoting when they say this I mean
this Andrea Dworkin when they say that
women have the right to hate their
oppressors now this is for me a
particularly scary aspect of it and it
goes it goes entirely for what the black
lives matter movement who all subscribe
to this kind of ideology it's the it's
the way of legitimizing hatred for
people based on what is perceived to be
social advantages so if they say well
you're a white man therefore you have
social advantages
therefore it
not bad for me to hate you you know I
can I can say all sorts of things to you
and it's okay because you have privilege
I'm oppressed you're privileged
therefore no matter what I say to you it
doesn't matter even though in an
impersonal inter inter interaction if
you say some horrible things me I'm her
but you know I'm I'm a regular person
like my white privilige isn't actually a
shield right horrible words yeah and
also it takes the distinction away from
someone from a male who is doing
everything he can to fight for women's
rights inequality annum and a man who is
against those things if you just say
that's white man or it's just men and we
saw this a great example of this I think
is a couple weeks ago with those Cologne
attacks and I saw all these feminists
writing articles and tweeting saying
things are this is it's not a this isn't
a migrant problem this isn't a religion
problem they were doing everything to
get it away from the identity of the
specific people who did this and try it
well this is a male problem this is
crazy this is actually crazy it's insane
what what happened in Cologne was
something called Taha Rush Jameer which
is just Arabic the group assault or
sexual assault and it's something that
happens I think the first instance of it
was I think was originally recorded in
the 50s but I guess it kind of wasn't
something really came to the surface
until about 2011 in the Egyptian Arab
Spring where I excuse the AC I think the
CNN journalist was basically surrounded
by a group of guys in Cairo and then
molested and you know forcibly molested
by Leonid gangs of men and this this
happened on New Year's Eve all across
Europe it happened in Stockholm Helsinki
orally attempted to in multiple German
cities and it was you know the the
police chief literally said nothing like
this has ever happened before
and so when feminists say well this is
just men we know that's wrong you know
we know that's wrong we know that it is
probably tied to retrograde attitudes
towards women coming from the Islamic
world you know I'm not saying every
Muslim all right
but you know you you can't go to the
Islamic world and look around and see
how things are and say that women are
treated the same hair as they are here
right so so that's a perfect segue to
this feminist and Islamist video that
you had mirrored who was the guy that
originally created the video right um
the video was originally done by a small
a small YouTube called site an atheist
okay so he created this cartoon video
and it's a song and it's basically a
feminist and an Islamist singing
together about why they sort of see the
world in the same way that was the
thrust of it and I saw the video and
before all hell broke loose about it
before Richard Dawkins retweeted it I
saw it and I thought it was pretty
brilliant it's a it's a great satirical
take down of this regressive nonsense
now I didn't realize at the time that
apparently the the female character
playing the piano apparently that was
actually based off a real person right I
didn't know that it's since the Islamist
the the Islamist is a youtuber called
Dawa man who um he runs around
proclaiming Islamism you know saying
that everyone should battle to Islam and
all that sort of thing so it wasn't you
know it wasn't victimizing anyone in
particular
I mean these are parodies of individuals
but they're individuals who have become
famous because of their terrible ideas
and attitudes right so and go ahead yeah
and I mean I had I I would love to say
that I wrote it or something but I
didn't I literally email the guy said I
really like your channel I want to help
promote you do me a piece of unique
content that I can put on my channel and
link back to you
um and so he sent me this video and I
saw I put it up and and yeah on all hell
broke loose when Richard Dawkins
retweets me so basically all Dawkins did
was retweet this and suddenly his
Twitter feed blew up and he was deep
platformed
from a speaking event at the NEC SS I
think it's the Northeast Conference of
secular skeptics skeptics and secularism
something close to that he was deep
platform from it they and they D
platform him without even telling him
there wasn't even a phone call that he
didn't ask for an explanation he then
made a public statement to virtue signal
that's the important thing they were
telling you
progressives look you know we're deep
platforming him because he has done
something transgressive to us you know I
will show everyone elsewhere on where
we're at the front single you know this
is a terrible thing the only being
Richard Dawkins was probably a big draw
for that place you know me of course you
know he they might get three four
hundred people that Richard Dawkins has
millions of followers you know he's
doing them a favor so the you know they
they have they've kind of shot
themselves in the foot and they've just
made themselves with really intolerant
because his original tweet was obviously
as a feminist myself this doesn't apply
to all thumb this but there is
definitely a pernicious minority and
learn behold the pernicious minority
rose up and you know got in his face and
it's like a well you're just proving the
point of the video right so you're
literally proving the point of the video
you're literally proving that these two
groups for all the wrong reasons have
become partners that there's one
ideology that that feminists
unfortunately or some degree of
feminists seem to be okay with and it's
the same ideology that would do the
worst to women yes it's hard to believe
that we even as I'm saying it I'm
thinking this is completely bonkers it
is absolutely bonkers 'im without
intersectional ISM it doesn't make any
sense at all you know but when again
you've got to think in section so you
think right white person and brown
person then man woman you know and say
okay what the question is what is the
most oppressive thing so a man
oppressing the woman that's quite bad
but a white person oppressing a brown
person that's much worse and therefore
now we're talking about a bunch of brown
people being oppressed by a bunch of
white people and so the fact that men
and women are oppressing each other
Brown whether oppressing white women
that's not so important
the important bit is the skin color
above the sex which I'm genuinely
surprised that I thought feminists would
go the other way I thought that they
would be more concerned about men
oppressing women than brown people as
being oppressed by white people but
apparently they're not yeah apparently
right so in your estimation then knowing
the way the feminist movement has
evolved and obviously I've had christina
hoff sommers on the show and I've talked
to her about some of this stuff what
would you say is the bet if you
just want true equality for the sexes
you're married to a woman you like women
you know sexual guy that likes women
right what would you say is the best way
for men and for women for anyone that
cares about the ideas of feminism to go
out and act on those ideas um I mean
honestly I think one of the problems
that feminism has now modern feminism
has is this right I have dragons to slay
you know I mean men and women have
complete legal equality I can't think of
it whenever a feminist is challenging
you to say oh you know the men are
oppressing women ask them what legal
rights men have over women they can't
leave one there just aren't any and so
we're at the point now where I mean I I
don't know what more needs to be done we
seem to be living in quite stable
liberal democracies where merit matters
I mean obviously in everything it is a
lot of a lot of what it is is who you
know rather than what you know but merit
still matters you know you can't just
hire someone for their arbitrary
characteristics if they can't do the job
any no one no one thinks that so I mean
I personally I just think I've done
don't make judgments based on racial
gender or you know or transgenderism or
you know homosexuality or anything like
that these characteristics that
generally aren't very useful to judge
people on I mean you know you're being a
white man doesn't in any way inform how
good an interview you are you know I I'm
I'm not watching you because you're a
white man and I'm watching you because I
like the guest you have on I like what
the questions you ask I like the answers
you get out of them you know none of
that has anything to do with you being
white or male or straight or gay or
anything like this
they're completely pointless and
arbitrary characteristics that don't
really apply right so really all we have
to do is just keep hammering the point
home right if we're for people that want
to remove this identity politics stuff
we just have to keep hammering that
until it becomes so obvious and I do
think that's where and this is where we
can sort of pivot to a little more of
the regressive tactics this is where we
can really beat them there they're tough
to beat because we know they're gonna
lie we know they're gonna cheat and
misinform people and all of those things
but we can keep hammering them with is
we want equality for everybody
regardless of borders and nationality
and religion and everything else yeah
the the fundamentals of the fundamental
principles of liberalism are universal
that's that was the great the great gift
of sort of English liberalism is
individual rights and universal
principles that you and then wrong you
know we've not always applied these at
you know evenly or anything like this
and inna initially they were exclusively
for white heterosexual men at the very
top of the pyramid but the point is that
the principles obviously lend themselves
to cascading downwards because as soon
as you have some people who are
espousing these principles there is no
good reason not to extend the franchise
to everyone which is why we now have
universal suffrage you know it you can't
there's no justification to not you know
the all of the justifications given
we're all obviously faulting which is
why we're now at the point where we are
so yeah it just basically stayed true to
your own principles if you think it's
wrong to judge by race don't judge
people by race it doesn't matter what
what race they are if you think is wrong
to judge by people by sex don't judge
people by sex you know and the all I can
say is that these are timeless
principles that will always be relevant
you know there will never be a time
where someone says you know actually it
is because I'm black that I should be
judged you know it is because I'm a
woman that I should be judged and it's
only because these people have they've
got a lot of good and very slippery
language and techniques to persuade
people that in fact you know given this
context it's right to do this whereas
I'm of the opinion that there is no
context in which it's right to judge
people based on characteristics they
have no control over you know if you
didn't get to choose it it's not a part
of your character it doesn't describe
you as a person it just describes your
body or your you know your physical
characteristics it doesn't describe what
you are like in your character so does
this do you think this also goes to the
feeling part of this because that's sort
of what I'm thinking as you're saying
this that there's there's a feeling that
I think this regressive ideology is
attached to so for example I can't give
you a as you just said I can't give you
an example where
stem eclis in the united states that
women are oppressed meaning that you
know there are now laws protecting you
know equal opportunity laws and things
like that now that doesn't mean that
women don't have a harder time related
to certain things if business deals for
example are being done on golf courses
and less women play golf well then
they're they're going to be excluded and
you could probably think of many many
examples like that but what that is
really more about is is a feeling not
sort of a systemic legal issue and i
think that's where people that's where
people struggle to to separate these
things yeah absolutely i mean you think
like um what's the what's the company
that does the sex toys
and summers and summers is a british
company i think and that it sell sex
toys it's it was created by a woman and
they're a large portion of the company
is run by women they probably don't do
their business deals on golf courses you
know they probably have I don't know
massive piles of nail salons or
something like so you know and I'm
sounds very typical but they don't go to
getting golf courses so I would have to
change my position of perspective and I
would have to go to where the the power
is mm-hmm in that situation and everyone
like you're right you know there are
going to be cases where you have you
know powerful CEOs who go golfing and
the way to get into their good graces
would be to go go them as well um you
know sometimes gotta make sacrifices on
tea but I I personally hate golfing yeah
but it wouldn't be the CEO of this
company or get you know I want to work
my way up the ladder I would take up
golfing you know it doesn't matter what
your gender it matters about how well
you golf you know yeah so you know I
likes it it's not a perfect system
either but it's better than the
alternative because one thing that
people will forget about quotas is as
soon as you start discriminating in
favor of someone because of skin color
sex ethnicity whatever you are also
discriminating against people on those
very same categories you know if you say
right we've got a position here we need
to hire a black woman then you are
excluding people on the basis of their
race and sex so I I can't agree with
that I think that's wrong
yeah if I'm sure there are plenty of
incredibly talented black women out
there therefore
don't need to make artificial
adjustments surely you know and at the
end late we if we go down this road then
where does it end where where is the
eventual logical goal eventually you
come to a planned economy where you
can't you can't just have uh no wheat
wheat well you're gonna hire by merit
but now you've got you know ten
different categories you've got to go
through you know how many only transmit
jamming queer people you how many black
white Hispanic you know and so now
you're not talking about how good they
are at their jobs now you're talking
about me just up Tory characteristics of
these people and what happens when like
if three people leave what you do three
black people leave your company and all
you have applying for jobs and white
people what do you do yeah you know
you're in a position where it's
ridiculous
yeah it's really crazy it's almost like
the the quest for equality is being
played sort of on an unequal playing
field and that just makes everybody kind
of nuts well I think I think Nietzsche
really did have it right when he when he
was saying that um you know be careful
when you're battling monsters because
when you stare long into the abyss the
abyss also stares into you you know and
if you if you stare long into the sort
of regressive mindset of the world is
terribly uneven it's an unequal there
are no opportunities for anyone there's
no end we need to do anything we can to
help them then everything becomes
justified you know they does matter
who's right you trampled on you're doing
it for the greater good
that's what really
you